bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
celle de parlement hebdo avec katie
vibert bon joker pour journée qu'elles
ont refait toute l'actualité politique
et parlementaire de la semaine et cette
semaine une semaine marquée évidemment
par la tension sociale les cheminots ont
poursuivi leur mouvement de grève pour
dire non à la réforme ferroviaire les
députés ont fini jeudi soir l'examen du
texte qui prévoit notamment le
regroupement de la sncf et réseau ferré
de france attention aussi au sein de la
majorité les fondeurs ont présenté leur
amendement au collectif budgétaire
manuel valls et déplacés au palais
bourbon pour tenter de calmer la grogne
s'est invitée à la réunion du groupe
socialiste c'était mardi dernier et puis
le dossier alstom general electric ou
siemens mitsubishi qui va remporter la
mise chacun des deux groupes a renchéri
son heure pour reprendre le fleuron
industriel français du suspense dans
quelques jours nous accueillons pierre
moscovici merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes ancien
ministre de l'économie des finances
ancien ministre des affaires européennes
député socialiste du doubs alors vous
allez réagir à l'actualité chargée mais
d'abord c'est la coutume je vous propose
d'entendre ce que pensent de vous
certains de vos collègues je tremble
elle était un bon ministre des finances
il était dans le placer dans le
gouvernement jospin où nous étions
ensemble un bon ministre des affaires
européennes donc c'est quelqu'un de
compétent d'actifs un ensemble de
qualité important on avait proposé par
exemple qui est des écarts de salaires
qu'ils soient réduits dans les
entreprises on avait ensemble proposer
la banque publique d'investissement on
avait proposé une réforme fiscale et je
regrette que parfois quand elle était
ministre de l'économie et des finances
ils sont nés un peu éloigné avec des
mots qui ont fait un peu de mal comme le
ras-le-bol fiscale je trouve qu'il avait
une part de mystère et
part de mystère un peu un peu excessive
pour un vrai dialogue en tout cas entre
gouvernement et son opposition peut-être
même d'ailleurs ce qui lui pose plus de
problème entre un gouvernement où
aujourd'hui une personnalité de la
majorité ses propres collègues donc il
faut pierre moscovici résolvent ce
mystère je pense de permis ce que j'ai
ici que c'est un candidat
à la commission européenne et on attend
la décision qui va être prise à un
candidat français et c'est une bonne
chose il était venu faire une réunion
publique pendant la campagne électorale
dans ma commune et à la fin de la soirée
de nous avions terminé par une séquence
chirac version parce qu ici et là
c'était un grand moment de bonheur quand
elle a beaucoup de des loges de
compliments bon me nice et bon
commissaire européen vous serez pierre
moscovici le prochain commissaire
européen français c'est pas à moi de le
dire vous savez c'est pas un poste pour
lequel on fait campagne je vois que
telle ou telle exprime son intérêt
pourquoi pas moi je suis pas du tout
dans cette attitude ce que je sais c'est
que c'est le président la république qui
va désigner le commissaire français je
sais qu'il le fera en lien avec le
prochain président de la commission
européenne et pour ma part je dis les
accompagnent
qu'est-ce qui pourrait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui parce que je sais qu'il ya
entre le président la république le
premier ministre et moi un projet
préparé un projet partagé et ce projet
partagé c'est en effet que je puisse
représenter la france dans la commission
européenne avec si possible un grand
portefeuille comique mais la décision
elle se prendra le moment venu vous
savez si j'ai cette mission
parlementaire pendant six mois qui
consiste à évaluer la contribution des
politiques européennes à la croissance
et l'emploi ça n'est pas le fait du
hasard j'étais la semaine dernière à
berlin où j'ai rencontré monsieur chat
bleu monsieur gabriel les principaux
ministres du gouvernement de gala merkel
j'étais à bruxelles cette semaine ou pas
donc j'ai eu un long tête à tête avec le
président barroso mais aussi rencontré
le commissaire à l'énergie à la
macroéconomie la concurrence je serai à
londres mercredi prochain pour
moi c'est une mission parce que je crois
qu'il est important qu'on entende une
voix françaises sur l'europe une voix
françaises dans l'europe et une voix
européenne en france et moi j'étais 20
ans que je suis à l'interface entre
l'europe et la france j'ai été misés
sphère européenne en effet pendant cinq
ans j'étais vice-président du parlement
européen commises elles contreviennent
aux aides pour spa impie lancé une
expérience et c'est surtout un
engagement le roc gelé là je pense que
si la france s'éloigne de l'europe la
france n'a pas d'avenir je pense que si
l'europe redoute la france craint la
france ou s'éloigne de la france alors à
ce moment là si vous n'avez ans estimé
combien c'est pas comme ça que jason je
dirais il y a un projet clairement
partagés entreprise de la république et
moi même appelons c'est un engagement
mais cet engagement c'est au président
de la république le moment venu
d'annoncer sa propre décision on
atteindra donc prochainement cette
décision va commencer la semaine
évidemment par lundi ça commence sous
haute tension
le gouvernement est resté ferme et les
syndicats font durer le mouvement de
grève objet de la colère la réforme
ferroviaire qui a été examiné toute
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale on
voit ça avec françois goulard
sur le constat tous sont unanimes il
faut réformer le système ferroviaire est
sévère les derniers sceptiques que
s'adressent les premiers mots du
secrétaire d'état cette réforme ne porte
en rien atteinte à aucun des droits
existants nous avons simplement le
souhait contrairement à ce qui était
préconisée par d'autres de préparer le
service public à la concurrence pour le
rendre fort pour faire que ce ne soit
pas la logique de la privatisation des
profits qui l'emportent sur la
nationalisation des dettes car c'est
bien la dette colossale qui est au coeur
du texte de loi 44 milliards d'euros qui
s'alourdit chaque année d'un milliard et
demi pour la juguler le gouvernement a
imaginé de fusionner rff qui gère le
réseau et la sncf et donc de faire
partager la dette aux deux entités pour
les élus communistes
c'est un désastre qui s'annonce les
conséquences de cette dette scellé
confia le cncf ce sera les usagers qui
seront les premières victimes de
dysfonctionnements les cheminots sur les
conditions de travail mais aussi les
investissements c'est également ce que
reprochent les syndicats à ce texte mais
leur mouvement de grève a eu un effet
imprévu dans l'hémicycle poussan l'ump
dans les bras de la majorité nous nous
avons décidé d'avoir une attitude
responsable c'est à dire de ne pas faire
durer les débats et de ne pas bloquer la
machine parlementaire le gouvernement
obtient même des soutiens inattendus sur
son projet de loi les voix des
centristes
la réforme disséquer depuis un an et
demi en commission des lois s'est
profondément transformé près de 400
amendements ont été déposés dont une
soixantaine par les communistes
davos comme ici maintenant que la loi
est examinée est ce que cette grève
était légitime une grève n'est pas
illégitime le droit de grève est inscrit
dans la constitution et il n'ya jamais
d'illégitimité une greffe en revanche je
pense que cette grève n'a pas été
comprise et qu'elle n'a pas été approuvé
pourquoi parce que il y avait le
sentiment juste que cette réforme est
une réforme à la fois nécessaire une
réforme ambitieuse mais aussi une
réforme qui a été soigneusement préparée
je t'aime isolé comme et des finances
pendant deux ans je peux témoigner du
fait qu'ils aient dû très nombreux
contacts avec les syndicats avec les
groupes politiques et par ailleurs je
sais aussi que pendant le débat
parlementaire il y avait des marges de
l'activité qui géreront c'est une oeuvre
politique je n'ai pas je ne juge jamais
des hommes et des femmes qui font grève
ils prennent aussi un risque pour eux
mêmes ils font courir un risque à
l'entreprise 160 millions d'euros quand
même mais au final je dirais que là va
coûter cher car cette grève bon il faut
qu'elles s'achèvent à un moment donné
vous concernant c'est maintenant et je
pense que les français les français vous
savez souvent font la grève comme ça par
procuration ils sont aux côtés de ceux
qui manifestent si on côté de ceux qui
font la grève là c'était le contraire il
faut que chacun y réfléchit c'est à dire
que des gros seins quand je vous dis que
c'était légitime on n'est pas loin de
penser ça il faut que des grèves est un
sens est un écho là en l'occurrence
disons qu'elle n'a pas été convaincante
qu'elle n'a pas convaincu et donc il
faut savoir amour et arrêter une grève
accepter une réforme dès lors que cette
réforme en plus à trouver un large
consentement elle est nécessaire au nom
de l'europe les nécessaires pour
l'entreprise et la nécessaire pour le
pays et c'est ça qui n'est concerné ce
qu'elle est suffisante pour préserver le
rail français pour sauver le rail
français de la concurrence féroce qui
s'annonce à l'horizon à ce qu'elle ne
veut voir la concurrence ça existe il
faut pas se tromper
même si en l'occurrence il ya des
garanties sérieuses sur l'identité du
service public ferroviaire et c'était
majeur nous ont pas comme si le mot
concurrence était un mot horrible
affreux de vivons dans un monde qui est
un monde global où la concurrence la
compétition existe et la france plutôt
que de se protéger de la concurrence
doit se muscler pour être compétitive
encore une fois c'est pas une remise en
cause de l'identité de notre service
public mais voilà je pense que cette
grève 7
il n'est pas comprise effet la rivière
sako dit finalement mais encore une fois
je ne juge jamais un syndicat je
dialogue avec les syndicats quand je
suis au gouvernement j'observe quand je
suis au parlement mais je pense que là
en l'occurrence maintenant il faut
avancer il faut avancer vers la réforme
qui préserve notre outil ferroviaire qui
permet d'unifier les structures qui nous
place en bonne position pour jouer notre
rôle dans cet univers qui est celui du
ferroviaire l'échelle européenne et on
va parler maintenant de politique
verdasco ici avec une réunion très
tendue mardi à l'assemblée
la réunion du groupe socialiste aura été
plus longue que prévu où j'ai des
discussions et de la grogne le projet de
loi de finances rectificatif manuel
valls a dû faire le déplacement pour
tenter de calmer les esprits et la
fronde au sein de la majorité françois
molins les dirigeants du groupe
socialiste avait un double objectif
voter une opposition unanime sur le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
et surtout dissuader les députés de
l'ailé gauche de déposer leur propre
amendement dans l'hémicycle
ceux qui ne voudraient pas à soutenir le
gouvernement
auraient eux même à regarder où ils se
situent dans l'hémicyle que c'est aussi
simple que cela moi je demande
aujourd'hui qu'après débat qui après
dialogue avec le gouvernement nous le
souhaitions de la manière la plus
cohérente possible c'est quand même une
demande normale mais les frondeurs du ps
refuse cette dramatisation de la réunion
pas question de renoncer à la liberté de
déposer des amendements que nous allons
évidemment garder cette liberté mais
c'est vrai que nous sommes extrêmement
demandeurs que le groupe socialiste
puisse porter nos propositions et c'est
l'enjeu de cette journée qui est une
étape parmi d'autres il faut pas là la
sueur jouer à huit clos les députés ps
ont discuté du budget pendant plus de
deux heures la gauche s'est abstenue sur
le vote mais sans surprise le groupe a
validé les grandes orientations du
gouvernement et heine immense majorité
dans tous les votes qui se sont exprimés
ce matin et donc cela me donne confiance
pas seulement pour l'adoption de textes
budgétaires dans les prochains jours
mais sur la continuité
l'approfondissement d'une politique dont
le pays et les français ont besoin mais
le feuilleton du budget n'est toujours
pas terminée l'ailé gauche n'a renoncé à
rien le bras de fer avec le gouvernement
continue j'ai le sentiment que beaucoup
de choses de peuvent bouger encore et
cela nous permet de voilà de continuer
notre notre offensive de conviction le
suspense devrait durer jusqu'à fin
juillet avec le vote final du projet de
loi de finances rectificative
d'avenir de la gauche les frondeurs on
n'en parle plus de sept jours de la
semaine
bonjour denis jeambar jouer guitare et
dispos les chaînes parlementaires on a
entendu manuel valls en début de semaine
dire la gauche peut mourir le constat
est brutal c'est vrai ou pas trop pas je
crois pas que la gauche puisse mourir
mais en revanche les parties dans la
forme où ils sont et notamment le parti
socialiste peuvent évoluer pas sûr qu'il
faille s'attacher aux mots parti
socialiste il peut perdurer et je crois
qu'elle un problème qui n'a pas été
résolu depuis 20 ans on parle beaucoup
du bad godesberg parti socialiste l'a
pas fait mais c'est un problème quelques
appels à mon avis toute la classe
politique pas simplement la gauche mais
aussi la droite c'est la prise en compte
de la mondialisation et au fond ils ont
entendu pierre moscovici tout à l'heure
la prise en compte de l'europe le vrai
clivage aujourd'hui dans la classe
politique française c'est l'europe où on
y croit ou on n'y croit pas et il me
semble avoir entendu d'ailleurs dans un
couloir de la chaîne parlementaire un
jour gérard longuet dire moi je suis
beaucoup plus proche de françois
hollande ou de pierre moscovici que de
henri guaino pourquoi parce qu'il fait
le pari européen etc ne parie europe 1
fait qu'il ya des contraintes mais je
reviens à votre question initiale la
gauche elle va se transformer se
modifier mais la démocratie c'est
l'alternance et la gauche produire un
parti de gouvernement rénové donnez
pierre moscovici vous êtes d'accord avec
le constat de manuel valls la gauche
doit se transformer sinon elle va mourir
manuel valls est un thème qu'ils
évoquent depuis en réalité assez
longtemps
moi je vais écrire un livre c'est en
1993 qui s'appelait à la recherche de la
gauche perdu vous savez non la gauche ne
peut pas mourir dans la politique il ya
toujours des invariants ya une gauche il
ya une droite il ya un camp qui croient
davantage ou laisser faire au fait que
ce sont les forces du marché seul qui
agite l'économie à nîmes l'économie il a
un autre qui croient davantage que
l'action publique doit travailler la
réduction des inégalités et des
injustices mais elle ira donc toujours
une gauche et une droite c'est le cas
depuis la révolution française c'était
même le cas d'une certaine valeur vous
parle de la gauche mais chez vous tu
perds
ce qui ce qui est vrai c'est que une
forme politique un parti politique lui
n'est pas immuable il doit être capable
de se transformer la et sefyu qui était
le parti qui précédait le nouveau parti
socialiste d'alain savary puis françois
hollande a disparu le parti socialiste a
probablement épuisé son cycle historique
celui du parti d'epinay en réalité ça
fait sans doute un certain temps déjà et
maintenant maintenant nous sommes je
crois contraint ou conduit en tout cas à
réfléchir sur ce qu'est être socialiste
et social démocrate au 21e siècle ce que
là cela implique comme dose de
réformisme il faut être très ambition là
dessus ce que ça implique aussi comme
engagement européen et nous devons être
plus ambitieux là dessus le parti
socialiste est un parti qui doit être
européen sans ambiguïté complètement
c'est dans ses gènes et s'il y a
toujours cette ambivalence par rapport à
l'europe perçu comme une contrainte
perçu comme un problème et non pas comme
une solution ou comme une partie notre
projet alors nous sommes en difficulté
donc je pense qu'il va y avoir devant
nous dans les années qui viennent un
travail de refondation de refondation
idéologique de refondation identique de
refondation aussi de l'organisation
j'entendais l'autre jour jean christophe
cambadélis le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste parler de nouveau parti
socialiste je sais pas quel sera le
sigle ou quel est le cri parti sioniste
après tout ça c'est une marque qui dit
quelque chose pour les français mais le
nombre de nouveaux cas mais le contenu
mais l'organisation mais la façon de
faire de la politique
et l'organisation politique elle même on
a commencé avec le cumul des mandats il
peut y avoir encore d'autres réformes
fondamentales oui il faudra des
changements essentiels qui veut la
gauche prenne demain une nouvelle forme
qui nouveaux visages ils provoqueront
d'ailleurs des fractures et qu'on voit à
sa mort c'est aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on
appelle les frondeurs parce que vraiment
sur le fond quand on les écoute ils
n'ont pas le rapport que vous pouvez
avoir ou que la majorité du parti elle
peut avoir ou que le gouvernement actuel
peuvent avoir avec l'europe on voit bien
que leur raisonnement est déconnecté de
la perspective européenne donc ça peut
passer par des crises profondes vous
évoquez la traîne derrière cette vidéo
est la création du parti d'epinay on est
un peu à ce moment là en effet aussi
bien écouter évidemment il ya des
différences avec ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui frondeurs mais il ya
toujours eu des courants dans le parti
socialiste
mélenchon dre henri emmanuelli développe
une voix extrêmement constant sur ces
sujets depuis longtemps n'oublions pas
que le parti socialiste sur l'europe je
pense que ça a été d'ailleurs un très
grave problème pour lui s'est fracturé
au moment du référendum de 2005 donc
père
âgé qu'est ce que ça veut bien le parti
socialiste est capable de surmonter ce
type de crise et je pense en effet qu'il
y aura une majorité pour le gouvernement
vous pensez que la majorité
autour notamment d'une idée simple c'est
que si on n'est pas capable de faire des
économies en termes de dépenses
publiques pour réduire le déficit et
pour se désendetter alors à ce moment là
la france va sortir des clous et
disparaître des radars je crois aussi
qu'il est important que les mesures pour
les entreprises puissent entrer en
vigueur non pour moi le problème il est
différent et il est plus profond certes
c'est important les frondeurs mais c'est
un moment la vie politique je dirais pas
que c'est une péripétie c'est un
dialogue qu'il faut avoir avec eux et
non ils vont rester dans l'espace du
partition suis sur le banc mais la vraie
difficulté c'est le rapport avec les
français c'est le fait que nos
concitoyens doivent comprendre ce que
c'est qu'aujourd'hui développer une
politique de gauche et nous devons être
plus clair parcours l'a été jusqu'à
lundi lisibilité
vous savez moi je peux le dire j'ai été
misés commis des finances pendant deux
ans je pense que nous avons menées
député qui sécrètent lisait une
politique solide une politique crédible
une politique qui a réduit les déficits
et qui a amélioré la compétitivité
française et une politique qui redresse
le pays mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas
eu de compréhension suffisante peut-être
parce qu'au départ et j'en prends ma
part nous n'avons pas dit voilà qu'une
la situation congolaise constat voilà
les efl vous demandez voilà le chemin
mots et je crois que derrière tout ça il
ya à la fois un problème de lisibilité
de compréhension aussi un problème de
grille de lecture d'explication du monde
encore une fois je lui dis oui le
travail de refondation idéologique
intellectuels politiques il doit être
fait et doit être fait dans les régions
sur la loi de rectifier de rectification
du directeur des finances publiques
rectificatif pardon est-ce qu'il faudra
d'après vous en passer par là 49,3 ou
est-ce que le groupe parlementaire sera
derrière ce cette loi rectificatif et le
sentiment que incertain il n'est pas un
drame il ya 82 depuis la création de la
vème république d'abord n'oublions pas
que nous avons des outils constituent
elles il existe un outil constitue ciel
par définition il est fait pour ne pas
s'en servir si on peut s'en priver il
est fait aussi pour s'en servir c'est
nécessaire c'est pas à moi de le
dessiner mais j'ai entendu le premier
ministre s'est expliqué disant qu'il ne
souhaitait pas le faire mais qui n'était
pas non plus pour la re
parlementarisation c'est bien
l'expression qu'il a utilisée à outrance
de la cinquième roue l'être mais ce que
je crois c'est qu'un certain nombre de
gestes ont été faits certains gels qui
ont été levées des gestes fiscaux qui
devraient pouvoir je l'espère et je le
crois entraîné un votre majeur 149 3
merci beaucoup le nez jean bart et on va
parler justement de politique économique
avec la mise en garde de la cour des
comptes qui s'inquiète de la situation
budgétaire du pays et préconise des
idées chat comme le non remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur toi ou encore
l'augmentation du temps de travail
effectif dans les administrations son
premier président didier migaud était
auditionné par la commission des
finances de l'assemblée écoutez cet
échange avec la députée karine berger un
gel de 50 milliards
enfin une réduction de la tendance de 50
milliards des dépenses publiques un
impact récessif sur notre activité cela
va de soi je voudrais savoir quelle est
l'hypothèse que la cour des comptes a
c'est sur sa recommandation de baisse
supplémentaire des dépenses publiques
qu'elles combien de points de pipe elle
nous invite à abandonner dans les trois
prochaines années nous on raisonne à
partir de vos propres objectifs et ce
sont des projets des objectifs qui sont
proposés par un gouvernement et qui sont
approuvés généralement par un parlement
qui les votent madame berger vous avez
voté le programme de stabilité comme
vous avez voté la loi de programmation
dont donc nous ne raisonnons à partir de
ce que vous avez voté et lorsque je dis
il faut mettre davantage l'accent sur la
réduction de la dépense publique c'est
ce que vous avez voté alors vous êtes
pierre moscovici conseiller maître à la
cour des comptes est ce que le soc en
premier le président semble longtemps
que je n'ai pas joué mais c'est votre
corps
certain françois lendemain dans 30 ans
est-ce que c'est dans son rôle quand il
donne des leçons de bonne gestion à la
france et surtout est-ce que vous vous
assumez votre part de responsabilité
dans les résultats d'abord le point cour
des comptes le la peau j'ai évalué les
comptes publics enfin ça tombe de
diagnostic il ya aussi maintenant la
création d'un haut conseil des finances
puis je ne disputerai jamais de la
pertinence du travail de la cour mais
puisque ce sont des hypothèses il peut y
avoir un débat moi ce que je crois c'est
qu'il ya d'abord une chose qui est
possible et nécessaire c'est que la
perspective de croissance pour 2014 1%
soit tenue la france a les moyens de
faire ça et la politique pro
compétitivité le pacte de responsabilité
c'est fait pour ça c'est fait pour les
entreprises investissent c'est fait pour
qu'elles embauchent ça c'est ma première
conviction la deuxième c'est que les 50
milliards d'euros sont nécessaires et
qu'il est indispensable que ce cap là
soient tenus c'est la boussole c'est
lancre de notre crédibilité ça attendez
vous on le vit dans ce monde tout ça
roisième mais par définition il ya des
annonces des enveloppes qui ont été
annoncées c'était le cas lors du
discours de politique générale et puis
on va s'apercevoir loi de finances après
loi de finances qu'il s'agisse du projet
loi de finances rectificative du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif du prochain projet
de loi de finance vous apercevoir que
ces économies elle se déploie c'est
indispensable et vous savez je reviens
de berlin je reviens de bruxelles ça
c'est ce qui dicte la crédibilité
française après une dernière question
qui est celle qui aujourd'hui est dans
l'air c'est nous avons un pacte de
stabilité à l'échelle européenne on ne
peut pas remettre en cause ses règles
les allemands ne le veulent pas
il est fondamental que si un pays fait
des réformes alors à ce moment-là on
puisse en tenir compte c'est ce qu'on
appelle la flexibilité non pas remise en
cause du pacte mais peut-être
flexibilité nous quoi gérer dans son
application je ne suis plus aujourd'hui
le ministre des finances mais ce que je
constate c'est l'expérience est ce que
je sais c'est qu'à l'échelle européenne
j'en parlais avec olli rehn le
commissaire chargé de ces questions il
ya deux jours j'en parlais avec monsieur
barroso le constat qu'est une conscience
très claire que s'il n'y a pas plus de
croissance en europe s'il n'y a pas plus
d'investissement en europe alors il va y
avoir un décrochage entre les européens
et l'europe nous devons bâtir l'europe
de l'investissement nous devons
réorienter l'europe vers la croissance
et vers l'emploi ça peut passer par des
politiques dites microéconomique je
pense à la politique industrielle plus
forte et par des politiques macro
économiques qui soient plus intelligente
plus subtile vous avez regardé aux
prisonniers de cette règle des modems
sans club à berlin on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya cette conscience
oui il faut faire plus pour la
croissance notamment en france savait
quand je parle à zig marque abriel le
vice chancelier social démocrate ou un
vol via le chat bleu mon ami ou une
ancienne homologue que maudit style le
front national pour eux c'est un choc
c'est une préoccupation ils veulent que
la france soit plus forte et bien voilà
les besoins des plus de souplesse quand
vous de réclamer plus de flexibilité sur
le pacte de stabilité vous êtes entendus
par par les allemands la france a dit
qu'elle ferait trois pour cent elle peut
faire 3% en même temps il s'agit d'autre
chose il s'agit de voir comment dans les
cinq prochaines années nous sommes
capables de muscler la croissance
française française et européenne brutal
car si nous ne le faisons pas alors à ce
moment là je crains que le projet
européen soit compromis moi je souhaite
que on retrouve le sens et l'élan et du
projet auquel vous allez pouvoir faire
tellement encore en parler avec ce volet
économique qui concerne alstom siemens
et un lièvre au japonais mitsubishi
ils ont déposé une offre alternative à
celle de l'américain general electric
les deux pdg ont été reçus à l'elysée
auditionné également à l'assemblée
nationale on écoute tout seul ils sont
venus à paris défendre leurs offres
devant la représentation nationale
rassurer surtout des députés qui
s'inquiètent du possible démantèlement
d'alstom et d'éventuelles suppressions
d'emplois
je pense que si vous voulez le
démantèlement d'un stop eh bien vous
avez vous tourné vers les autres offres
les autres offres qui propose 12
milliards pour acheter les activités
dans le domaine de l'énergie qui alors
seront transférés à une autre société en
revanche si vous souhaitez qu'alstom
reste soit pérenne à long terme si vous
souhaitez sauvegarder des emplois si
vous souhaitez développer l'emploi et
bien il faut opter pour un partenariat à
long terme en parallèle de celui que
nous avons proposé en commun avec
mitsubishi l'allemand siemens s'est
allié au japonais mitsubishi
le premier reprendrait toute l'activité
turbines à gaz du groupe pour une valeur
de 3 9 milliards d'euros le second
rachèterait 10% du capital de
l'entreprise française en mettant sur la
table plus de 3 milliards d'euros leur
offre distille permettra de créer un
millier d'emplois mais la bataille pour
l'avenir d'alstom n'est pas fini le
conseil d'administration qui affiche
clairement sa préférence pour general
electric aura le dernier mot
le géant propose 12 3 milliards d'euros
pour toute la branche énergie du groupe
est ce que françois hollande peut dire
non à general electric
d'abord c'est le conseil migration
d'alstom qui pas se prononcer ensuite
les pouvoirs publics ont en effet une
capacité d'intervention là dessus
notamment depuis qu'un décret a été pris
qui permet de se prononcer sur ce type
de sujet vous savez moi je ne suis plus
aujourd'hui au coeur du dossier mais ce
que je peux dire c'est que j'ai
confiance je sais que cette décision
elle sera prise avec un seul critère
et ce critère sait quelle sera la
solution qui permette de préserver les
sites de production quelle sera la
solution qui permet d'avoir des centres
de décision en france quelle sera la
solution qui permette de préserver le
mieux notre indépendance énergétique
quelle sera la solution qui permet de
préserver l'intégrité groupe
general electric et elle sera la
solution qui permet de créer le plus
d'emplois ce que je veux dire par là
parce que je n'ai pas moi le détail des
offres il on parle en ce moment même en
parle sans arrêt une réunion hier soir à
l'élysée il y en a une aujourd'hui ce
matin l'elysée les chefs d'entreprise
vont être reçus les mises compétents
travail le président est manifestement
très concentrés sur le sujet ce que je
veux dire c'est que je suis persuadé
qu'au final le choix aurait été fait de
manière extraordinairement pragmatique
et ce qui compte c'est qu'on retienne la
meilleure offre et la meilleure offre
c'est celle qui préserve et développent
l'emploi et je n'ai pas moi exprime une
préférence arnaud montebourg lui s'est
battu contre general electric si jamais
c'est general electric est ce que c'est
la défaite d'arnaud montebourg c'est pas
comme ça que les choses se passent si au
final general electric a amélioré son
offre de telle façon et ça les pouvoirs
publics ont joué un rôle utile en doute
l'hypothèse que cette offre soit
meilleure que ce qu'elle était au début
est meilleure que celle d'un solide on
subit ci alors à ce moment-là personne
n'aura perdu six mois si c'est pas le
cas je raisonne pas là dessus je suis
plus là dedans je raisonne pas de façon
politicienne je raisonne pour l'intérêt
général du pays et pour faire en sorte
que nous soyons un pays rayonnant et
donc encore une fois la meilleure offre
ce qui compte c'est ce qui se passe pour
les salariés c'est ce qui se passe pour
la france la question de sa part pas
savoir qui a perdu ou gagné
politiquement ce qui doit gagner c'est
l'emploi et ce qui doit gagner c'est la
france le reste n'est - ce pas mme
ashton n'est pas un groupe comme un
autre c'est un secteur stratégique
et donc est ce que l'état doit utiliser
la fameuse arme dont elle dispose c'est
à dire je le décris sait jamais
j'imagine encore une fois au terme de ce
processus qui a été long qui était
compliqué on parviendra à sélectionner à
choisir la meilleure offre et la
meilleure offre encore une fois c'est
celle qui permet une france indépendante
descend de décision en france des sites
de pression
européen mais on avance plus les
européens sont alliées des japonais peut
pas dire qu'il ya d'un côté quelque
chose qui serait du genre boeing l'autre
côté airbus s'est pas exactement ça moi
ce qui compte encore une fois c'est
l'emploi savez en la matière ne lisons
pas cette affaire de manière
politicienne ça ça rabaisse tout on en
fait beaucoup trop de ses lectures là
moi je souhaite que quelle que soit
l'offre retenue ce soit la meilleure
pour le pays et pour alstom et surtout
pour les salariés d'alstom pour l'emploi
en france c'est le seul critère qui doit
nous a entendus repasser au mercredi
conseil des ministres est chargée
trois textes examinés par les miniers
tôt celui sur la réforme territoriale
quelles compétences pour les régions
quelle carte pour 2014 jean baptiste
daoulas pour le résumer
le conseil des ministres a validé une
réforme territoriale en deux temps avec
d'abord un projet de redécoupage des
régions examiné en juillet au parlement
les régions devrait passer de 22 à 14
un chiffre qui pourrait baisser si le
parlement vote diffusion supplémentaire
pourquoi pas entre la bretagne et les
pays-de-la-loire il ya des possibilités
peut-être selon les débats de voir la
carte se modifier mais les règles sont
assez simples sont assez claires peut
pas y avoir d'accroissement du nombre de
régions donc ça se fait à nombre de
régions équivalent et il ne peut pas y
avoir de démantèlement de région après
le redécoupage place à la répartition
des compétences entre les collectivités
locales c'est la sphère d'un deuxième
projet de loi examiné à l'automne au
parlement les départements vont perdre
leurs compétences elles seront
transférées vers les régions et les
intercommunalités jusqu'en 2020 ils
devront recentrer leurs actions sur
trois domaines le social le soutien aux
communes rurales et le financement des
services d'incendié les élections
régionales seront repoussées de mars à
décembre 2015 en même temps que les
élections départementales en 2020 une
réforme constitutionnelle devrait acter
la disparition des départements
pierre moscovici est ce que pour vous
cette réforme va à loin notamment en
termes d'économie escomptés tous les
autres pays européens en tout cas les
grands comme l'italie par exemple on
fait des réformes importantes pour
repenser leur carte c'est la femme qui
va générer les économies sans aucun
doute c'est surtout une réforme qui doit
produire plus d'efficacité en faisant en
sorte que les régions aient plus de
compétences économiques et que ces
régions est une taille qui leur
permettent de peser à l'échelle
européenne je pense que cette réforme
après il y aura d un débat parlementaire
qui peut à la fois d'informer les choses
peuvent bouger mais c'est réforme est
une réforme nécessaire attendu
on dit souvent la france ne fait pas de
réformes de structure on a critiqué la
gauche pour ça ça c'est vrai faut une
structure massive majeure qui va compter
énormément à l'issue de ce créateur
originaire du doubs en tout cas c'est
votre département sélection
variée avec la franche comté la
bourgogne ça vous plaît je pense qu'il
faut à la fois faire ce mariage là ne
pas toucher aux frontières régionales
mais en même temps qu'il faut être
capable de tenir compte des bassins
économiques et sociaux peut-être dans la
reformulation des intercomités ou des
départements je prends un exemple je
suis lu du pays de montbéliard juste à
côté pile montbéliard il ya belfort
tenez par exemple avec ji et alstom et
puis à 50 kg mattia mulhouse c'est en
alsace il faut que cette zone là ce
qu'on appelle les rues urbaines belfort
montbéliard et le sud alsace puis se
trouver des formes pour travailler
ensemble demain même si c'est pas la
même région donc si vous voulez il
faudra aussi réfléchir à ça les
batailles économiques et sociaux les
bassins de vie c'est sûr que moi je me
sens plus proche de mulhouse que dijon
dont je serai dans la mairie origination
je souhaite être de même
en attendant il ya un autre grand
dossier du quinquennat qui est arrivé la
transition écologique le projet de loi
s'est fait désirer ségolène royal a
dévoilé mercredi transports plus propres
maisons plus vertes mais aussi moins de
nucléaire les grandes lignes du texte
avec jérémy hartmann longtemps reportés
enfin dévoilé le projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique comporte 80
articles sa priorité l'habitat ségolène
royal veut faire de la rénovation
thermique des logements le pilier de sa
loi un allègement fiscal de 30 % est
prévue pour les travaux d'isolation
engagé entre le 1er septembre 2014 et le
31 décembre 2015 les français vont voir
diminuer leur facture donc ils vont être
aidées pour faire ces travaux
aidées par des allègements d'impôts
aidés par des prêts à taux zéro et
départ le tiers financeurs pour engager
les travaux et pour qu'ensuite leurs
factures de chauffage et d'électricité
baysse un chèque énergie sera également
distribué aux ménages les plus modestes
il remplacera les tarifs sociaux du gaz
et de l'électricité en matière de
transport le texte fait la part belle
aux véhicules électriques
il prévoit l'installation de sept
millions de bornes de recharge d'ici
2030 sur tout le territoire en revanche
pas de taxes diesel c'est à dire pas
d'alignement du prix du gazole sur celui
de l'essence quand les gens gagnent pas
beaucoup d'argent et ne peuvent pas
n'ont pas les moyens de remplacer leurs
vieux véhicules diesel et qu'ils ont été
incités à acheter du diesel c'est pas du
jour au lendemain qu'on va les punir et
les empêcher de rouler avec leur voiture
concernant le nucléaire l'engagement de
réduire sa part de 75 à 50% dans notre
production électrique d'ici 2025 sera
inscrit dans la loi mais seuls edf
l'exploitant des centrales peut décider
d'arrêter un réacteur dans son texte le
gouvernement ne prend donc aucun
engagement concernant des fermetures de
centrales en revanche il plafonne la
capacité de production nucléaire
française à son niveau actuel autrement
dit si edf souhaite mettre en marche le
père de flamanville il faudra qu'ils
arrêtent d'autres réacteurs en échange
on l'a vu il ya plusieurs propositions
presque consensuel a en tout cas sauf
une fête du nucléaire est ce que ça peut
devenir la ligne de fracture avec vos
amis les verts par exemple
écoutez je pense qu'il ya un engagement
qui a été pris par le président la
république et une mise en oeuvre qui est
là sa firme je rappelle que nous avons
vécu pendant deux ans en au gouvernement
avec cet accord oui mais l'accord est
bon pour le reste c'est surtout un texte
ambitieux sur un sujet qui est un sujet
majeur et si je peux ajouter une toute
petite chose il est important que cette
dimension de 13 transition énergétique
soit abordée au niveau européen et
notamment en franco allemand parce que
nous n'avons pas les mêmes modèles
énergétiques nous devons aller vers la
transition et le faire en bâtissant une
politique européenne de l'énergie ont
parlé de la prochaine commission
européenne cette politique européenne de
leener j c'est un des sujets marie sur
quelle base le ton construire 7 cette
nouvelle politique avec m en faisant en
sorte qu'il n'y ait plus 28 marchés
séparés d'un marché unique générera pour
le coup des économies considérables qui
pourraient
si vous voulez oui pourquoi pas c'est
jeudi à l'assemblée nationale y ait une
candidature qui ne plaît pas du tout
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
jacques toubon futur défenseur des
droits point d'interrogation la
candidature a été proposée par le
président de la république sauf que ça
ne plaît pas beaucoup à l'assemblée
nationale marie là bas vous résume tout
cela
jacques toubon ancien ministre et député
rpr proposé par françois hollande au
poste de défenseur des droits un choix
d'ouverture que certains à gauche
n'approuve pas donc c'est un poste où il
faut être très fin et où il faut être
irréprochable et il faut réunir le
consensus ce n'est pas le cas de jacques
toubon je peux comprendre que l'on
puisse dire qu'il a changé certes tout
le monde peut changer mais jacques
toubon quand même un lourd passé dans
certaines décisions qu'il a prises
certaines positions qu'il a avancée car
jacques toubon et principalement
contesté pour avoir entre autres voté
contre certaines dispositions dans la
dépénalisation de l'homosexualité ou
dans l'abolition de la peine de mort
alors même si les dirigeants de la
majorité avaient préalablement été
consultés sur le sujet aujourd'hui
manuel valls claude bartolone ou encore
bruno le roux ont bien du mal à défendre
la candidature du président l'est peut
être encore temps pour jacques toubon
pour le prêt des landes la république
que les deux de regarder si cela
correspond à la meilleure proposition
pour être officiellement validé la
nomination de jacques toubon devra
d'abord être discuté et voté par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale puis par celle du sénat un
vote favorable de deux cinquièmes des
députés sera alors nécessaire la droite
est donc mobilisés on est en plein dans
la manifestation
d'une idéologie qui se croient toute
puissante et qui se permet de jeter une
fatwa sur un ancien ministre de la
république
sur un homme qui a toujours eu le
courage de ses opinions nous sommes en
république et en démocratie aujourd'hui
ce manque d'adhésion autour de la
proposition du président sonne
clairement comme un désaveu
car le comble serait qu'elle soit sauvée
par l'opposition résultats attendus le 9
juillet prochain
quelle est votre position sur cette
polémique pourquoi jacques toubon ne
ferai t pas bon défenseur gt3 mexique
en l'occurrence j'en suis heureux
c'est bien le cas tragique mais c'est
d'abord c'est une c'est une proposition
du président la république il faut la
prendre comme tel elle doit être prise
en considération le présent n'avait plus
qu'un souci qui est d'éviter le
sectarisme rappelons que le précédent
défenseur des droits était le regretté
dominique baudis pour le reste il
reviendra à la commission des lois
d'examiner le passé le présent les pires
ennemis ans comme ici ça veut dire le
mot sectarisme pour être très clair donc
et donc il faudra que cela se fasse avec
un examen très objectifs et dans une
atmosphère qui ne soit pas une
atmosphère passionnée jacques toubon a
des qualités il a des défauts ces
nouveaux députés ensuite de se prononcer
jean paul mot sectarisme ou qui on avait
parlé ce qu'ils voteraient contre
justement ferait preuve de sectarisme
j'ai pas dit ça je sais qu'il faut que
je dise que le président a répliqué mais
le souci de nous faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas l'installation d'un état ps
et en l'occurrence il y avait auparavant
un défenseur des droits qui venait de
l'opposition d'aujourd'hui pour le monde
souhaitait faire une proposition qui
s'inscrit dans le même camp le mot secte
arrive je lui ai emprunté manuel vals
soyez vous mais en même temps je conçois
que ça pose des problèmes les
difficultés et qu'il y ait un débat très
serré sur ces sujets il doit être à la
fois très précis très minutieux et en
même temps très serein déciderons en
tout cas je vous propose de terminer
cette émission avec un conflit social
qui a marqué les esprits un documentaire
diffusée sur lcp revient sur lcp et
public sénat revient sur la fermeture du
site psa d'aulnay-sous-bois c'est notre
plus de l'hebdo
juillet 2012 les salariés du site
peugeot citroën d'aulnay-sous-bois se
retrouvent sans emploi leur usine ferme
ses portes françois hollande promet
qu'il ne laissera pas faire en vain les
réalisateurs ludovic fossard et francine
raymond sont retournés sur les lieux
extrait avec simon barbarie un cauchemar
devenu réalité un licenciement vécu
comme un deuil un matin de juillet 2012
les salariés du site psa peugeot citroën
d'aulnay sous bois apprennent abassourdi
la fermeture de leur usine ne plus
savoir quoi faire être perdu voilà
s'être perdus se dire mais qu'est ce qui
se passe
il ya une dame qui se greffait est gris
fait comme ça le documentaire psa les
mots de la fin de francine raymond et
ludovic fossard suit le processus
douloureux d'un conflit social
emblématique de notre époque espoirs
trahison bras de fer négociations les
auteurs ont recueilli les témoignages de
quatre anciens ouvriers du site qui ont
choisi de se battre pour améliorer leurs
conditions de départ un combat solitaire
et ce malgré les promesses du pouvoir
politique leblanc en l'état n'est pas
acceptable donc ne sera pas acceptée
cadre il faut engager une concertation
pour que signé aucun licenciement sec
chez peugeot le gouvernement sera
finalement impuissant devant le choix
stratégique du groupe si l' empathie à
l'égard de ceux qui ont mené la grève
jusqu'au bout baigne ce documentaire pas
de réquisitoire non plus les arguments
de la direction sont entendus les
divisions entre grévistes et non
grévistes sont abordés surtout cette
mise en perspective d'un conflit social
au travers les souvenirs de ses
principaux acteurs met le doigt sur des
problématiques plus larges comme la
désindustrialisation synonyme de chômage
de masse
sa fermeture et garder les devises
les mots de la fin un documentaire qui
rappelle durement que dialogue social
rime souvent avec rapport de force
inégal
voilà pour ce beau documentaire alors
pierre moscovici les présidents se
succèdent promettant de sauver qui des
emplois qui des sites et puis ces sites
fermés ce que l'état est devenu
impuissant face à la à ces grands
groupes notamment dans le second dans le
temps n'est pas du tout dire qu'en
france hollande avait dit le plan
inacceptable en l'état il n'a pas été
acceptée en l'état il a été modifié
notamment faisant notamment faisons en
sorte qu'il y ait une radicalisation du
site que les engagements soient pris
envers les travailleurs et ça c'est tout
à fait fondamentale vous savez moi je
garde une fierté et c'est une douleur la
fermeture d'aulnay bien sûr mais le site
n'avait plus de viabilité donc il
fallait aller vers autre chose mais je
garde une fierté je suis député du doubs
je suis député vert des députés de
sochaux est commise et l'économie les
finances ma fierté c'est d'avoir permis
que le groupe psa qui était dans une
extraordinaire difficulté se sauver et
qu'ils se sauvent en avec l'implication
de l'état français qui est entré au
capital avec un partenaire chinois et
avec des engagements pris sur l'emploi
sur la création de véhicules dans chacun
des sites sur le maintien de chacun des
sites et je pense qu'encore une fois
c'est cette démarche là qu'il faut
poursuivre non quand je quand j'ai agi
pour peugeot nous n'avons pas été
impuissant cette entreprise nous lui
avons donné une garantie d'état de 7
milliards d'euros pour sa banque sinon
il y avait plus de véhicules et puis
nous avons fait en sorte de grosse
structure et son capital avec des
engagements industriels je pense que
l'état doit se battre pour l'industrie
qu'il faut le faire avec subtilité qu'il
faut le faire avec pragmatisme ça a été
ma marque de fabrique et sommes tous les
gars de ça une fabrice grille est ce que
l'europe n'a pas aussi son rôle à jouer
et l'europe a son rôle à jouer c'est
pour ça que j'ai évoqué une politique
industrielle européenne mais si je
prends l'exemple on dit beaucoup
l'europe est un problème la politique de
la concurrence d'un problème moi sur ce
sujet là j'ai travaillé avec joaquim
almunia commissaire la concurrence il
arrive qu il les discussions avec
d'autres mais qu'il s'agit de la
garantie d'état ou qu'il s'agisse de la
restructuration du capital nous sommes
parvenus à un accord l'europe doit être
la solution est pas le problème et c'est
à ça qu'il faut travailler pour
réconcilier les français avec l'europe
futur commissaire européen pierre
moscovici peut-être européens de toute
façon européen toute façon bien engagée
parce que je suis persuadé que sans
l'europe la france est foutue merci
beaucoup je fais merci à tous de votre
fidélité rendez vous la semaine
prochaine